no sei pazza per la quasi presa non
ridere perché i trials manachino stralis
qui va bene va bene a fare un intro
vella passivi sempre a detta sono gli
altri si vede che sono un po dimagrita
ma lasci spingono parti viene anche lo
volevo fare questo come l'aria si mai ai
capelli pettinati grazie a tutti ragazzi
e benvenuti a questo motivo sono fuori j
premi come si fa questa cosa come loro
ispirazione cosa è la tutti c'è per
tutti i ragazzi si cura imparato faccio
io non so il mio video questo almeno nel
mio figlio mi fai fare posto vuol dire
qualcosa
siamo qui perché abbiamo deciso di fare
una roba molto intelligente rispetto ai
nostri standard
avete presente quando tirato fuori nel
video le caramelle tutti i gusti b1 e
avevo detto che avrei fatto la sfida con
qualcuno chi sceglie che si parla di
harry potter che culo la cosa che volevo
a casa che volevo dirvi praticamente
funziona che greta mi ha dato questo bug
questo si vede bellissimo questo
bellissimo barattolo neanche troppo
femminile dove andremo a mettere le
caramelle a turno dovremo prendere dal
barattolo una caramella senza guardare
dovremo indovinare di che caramella si
tratta quindi se io beh pesco il gusto
mito devo dire vomito che esce verme di
terra note la cambiati
l'ultima esperienza sono contento che mi
vuoi bene mi fa la cortesia di tenere il
barattolo mentre io apro molto gentile
nei wings che vai ferma meta ma vuole ce
ne sono a terra questa mattina
chiudo gli occhi pieni di the queen di
teco così vaio ok questo anche la bella
e buona per indovinarla fa schifo di
pomodoro visto il fumo d'oro quando
prima cosa va fatta la squadra mobile
cosa segreta che sto soffrendo perché la
caramella fa sì che chic che sono
vestito voglia di immaginare però comito
hai peccato quella comito subito che
c'era tanto schifo
voglio morire per le ragazze ma già così
schifo unholy union me ne vado mi alzai
la domanda questa cosa mi alzo e me ne
vado che fa schifo ti odio e buonissima
buonissima sull intervento chiaro cazzo
no no non sa di calcio sa dire anche il
colore di me la prima bello mi hai dato
all'inizio però sia stata buona e me lo
ricorderò cosa penso
ok con me forse dico no è positiva
davvero stai mentendo quando non sono
state guardai afragola ciliegia di
nostro pugno verso i miei gioielli ma
che mai lottato con marinella che ne
sono gentile weidmann da veramente lui
posso cambiare parte la colata casa ora
che non fa schifo
lei futuro ma che ti stai sbagliando non
so che cosa hai visto non fa schifo dai
sei single ladies ancora telai acqua
bianca a causa tampone ma buono sano
sapone ma no non sapone tuberose
campagna di caramella bianca temporale
proprio dio ma movimenterà mente per bob
imbandita che il governo e mi stava e
buona nabuk vai o non morde e buona dai
è beccata buona o siamo a due
qualche giocata io cambierei subitissimo
mi però non lo faccio perché io sono una
persona tutta jolo maschi fissi monina
che cos'è anche schifo verme di terra
che larice schifo orribile venire faceva
veramente stare veramente orribile non
voglio più fare basta chiudiamo qui ma
c'è qualcuno che si è mangiato un verme
di te ma per capire come rosa caramella
buona pack o no però poteva andargli
molto peggio cioè nel senso di terra
a terra e basta che mi spiace che la
piccola ma già vinto i prati non lo so
non ho capito e ragazzi se portate fuori
creta menchi piatto e di terra imposta
da brava ma dalla maniera mente questo
tavolo è raccontata ma come causa forse
dai e questa barca e momenti per buono
allora se gli ho detto che vuoi
indovinare cosa e melone milioni prato
lo rivela prato sarà come mescola via
vai vai vai vai a questa ma per te la
grecia c'è nel pd e riportano lo dice
silente cerume sfruttata meno al caso
tuo
64 è che manca non hai vinto perfetto
aspetta che non meno nulla dai vestivo
ma la tengo è una cosa che non dovrebbe
essere una caramella
ma il cibo quindi sia il titolo è però
c'è sono un signore non disputare anche
match point è un buon a mare si
questa situazione è il cibo poteva
andarci peggio
vabbe dai viviamo era la madonna fa così
schifo
rispuntano dio chiamato un dottore bene
ho vinto io ma cos'era affitto per forza
la regina delle caramelle di harry
potter si conferma essere greta ha visto
letti si ok ti sta bene tisba il karma
becomes così facendo
avevo anche il barattolo colgo
l'occasione per fare un annuncio tipo
svendopoli beni per i quali luca filippo
dite ce l'ha mai fatto questa challenge
solo per cui vendere il bollino brindisi
mi prendetevi ad hogwarts se notiamo una
giocata di solito le corde i ragazzi è
morta pazienza e band ormai ogni tipo
dai noi abbiamo appreso non so cosa ho
preso di micro sopreso gioia mare magno
gioia che provvede al riuso tutto nella
mia busta di stato riprenderà quindi 20
noi lori provini bene a chi prendi
disponibili che io no bravo a scuola
faccio le cose
dormo possiamo basta questo bollitore io
concludo qui questo questo incredibile
challenge cos'erano challenge l'avete
spero che vi sia ricevuto e allora so
come dice mio
aspetta
wait wait wait and see addirittura
street iscrivetevi decidiamo nuovi di un
bel i ragazzi perché i mezzi che mai